during the upcoming climate change
negotiations in Copenhagen this December
developing nations will be asking for
more generous and more reliable funding
for adaptation projects poor countries
will likely be the most affected by the
impacts of climate change and least able
to cope with them in September I hiked
for 21 days into northern Bhutan to see
how the tiny Himalayan nation is dealing
with a warming world the landscape of
northern Bhutan is peppered with
glaciers but the glaciers are retreating
rapidly an experts say they could
disappear completely by 2035 the silt
and boulders pushed aside by the
glaciers form natural dams that hold in
meltwater
some of these dams have given way to
produce deadly and destructive floods in
the river valleys where most of Bouton's
population lives
now AG Yelchin is a local yak herder he
invited me into his home and over a cup
of salty butter tea told me how the
fields in front of his house were washed
away by the last flood
my final destination was the Thor Tommy
glacier near the border with Tibet
I climbed to the top of the dam at the
foot of the glacier and saw for myself
how quickly the glacier is melting as
more ice melts pressure is building up
behind the dam scientists are worried
that it could soon collapse unleashing a
torrent of water from throw me into rap
string Lake to its west and on into the
valley below karma tip is leading a
project to reduce the pressure on the
dam and prevent a catastrophic flood in
the outlet from the melting glacier
hundreds of Bhutanese laborers scrape
away boulders and stones to deepen the
outlet and increased drainage the
project's aim is to lower throat Omi's
waters by one point six seven metres
every year but they're running behind
the team's crude measuring stick shows
that after the first year they've only
managed around 90 centimeters
the town is a bit of a pioneer in terms
of adaptation projects as a follower of
the Buddhist tenet of non extremism the
monarchy has prioritized economic
development but not at the expense of
the country's natural environment and
cultural traditions whereas many
developing countries have struggled to
get funding for their projects Bhutan
was the first country to get money from
a special United Nations fund for
adaptation projects in the developing
world
but even after 7.4 million dollars of
investment the project is only dealing
with one of the country's almost 3000
glacial lakes floods are only the tip of
the iceberg in terms of the consequences
of melting glaciers with all the water
and ice I saw on my trip it's hard to
imagine water shortages here but if the
Himalayan glaciers disappear it will
affect the water supply of around 750
million people in Bhutan and the rest of
Asia
you